[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono le 5 30 del mattino
londra 12 agosto 2012
spengo la sveglia anche se quella notte
in realtà non ho dormito parecchio
perché fra un ora c'è un pullman che mi
porterà a giocare la partita più
importante della mia carriera
la partita che vale una medaglia
olimpica ora serve una premessa come
avete intuito quando sono entrato sul
palco io non sono stato un grande atleta
che è diventato un allenatore di
pallavolo che un po lo stereotipo
classico del mondo dello sport mi
piacerebbe raccontarvi come fa qualche
mio collega che ero molto bravo ha molto
talento poi mi sono fatto male e ho
dovuto incominciare ad allenare
no ero sano come un pesce semplicemente
non avevo talento a sufficienza per
diventare un atleta cosa che mi sarebbe
piaciuta moltissimo matia vi ha
raccontato anche del mio giro che è
stato un giro un po lungo ho
incominciato davvero ad allenare in
questa città che la mia città in un
oratorio di questa città di un bordeaux
e siam borgo san paolo ho incominciato
da lì un percorso che è passato
attraverso cinque campionati diversi
dieci città diverse tre nazioni l'italia
la grecia la finlandia che sono parti
del mondo che mi hanno fatto diventare
quello che sono diventato pensavo un po
a queste cose quella mattina alle 5 e
mezza
sapendo che quel pullman sarebbe partito
un'ora dopo per portarmi al escort
il posto il luogo dove la nostra squadra
avrebbe giocato quella partita
le scorte è una di quelle architetture
resistenti cioè quelle architetture che
sono state capaci di cambiare nel corso
della storia la loro destinazione d'uso
pensate che alla fine dell'ottocento
lì c'era la sede europea del buffalo
bills wild west show
pensate quanti sogni sono transitati di
lì poi all'interno di quella struttura
pensata soprattutto per i grandi eventi
musicali nel 1973 david bowie fece un
concerto che siglò il record storico di
persone che erano andate ad assistere a
un concerto rock indoor nel 1992 un
nuovo edificio
tanto per essere coerente con questo
luogo di produzione di sogni venne
inaugurato di una principessa lady diana
e poi in occasione del trentesimo
edizione dei giochi olimpici londra 2012
quel posto era stato scelto per essere
il luogo dove si sarebbero disputate
alle partite di pallavolo
insomma quello era in quel giorno il
teatro dei miei sogni
purtroppo era molto lontanissimo era
lontanissimo da dove stavamo noi era a
più di un'ora di tragitto in condizioni
normali
però quel giorno tanto per complicare un
po le cose
c'erano due fatti il primo quello era
l'ultimo giorno dei giochi olimpici il
giorno in cui si corre la maratona e la
maratona quel giorno passava anzi
arrivava nel centro di londra che quindi
era completamente paralizzata
il secondo fatto era che la nostra
partita aveva una radio di inizio un po
particolare le 8 e 30 del mattino ora la
pallavolo è uno sport di forza esplosiva
non è un capriccio non è questione di
allenamento o di abitudine è molto
difficile essere performanti
a quell'ora del mattino è un fatto
biologico in poche parole nessuno dei
miei atleti aveva mai giocato una
partita che incominciasse a quell'ora
era tutto completamente nuovo erano una
situazione una sensazione completamente
sconosciuta
era tutto meravigliosamente in
allenabile nessuno dei nostri protocolli
tutte quelle cose che nello sport si
fanno con grande precisione con grande
attenzione ai dettagli
sembrava essere utile quel giorno
nessuna
o forse una sì perché su quel pullman
che mi avrebbe portato al teatro dei
miei sogni
io incominciamo a realizzare che quello
che mi stava capitando lì seduto col mio
sacchettino con la colazione dentro un
panino e un succo di frutta
così come si fanno le gite scolastiche
quella sensazione era molto vicina era
molto più vicina a quello che avevo
fatto venticinque anni prima quando in
questa città allenavo quei ragazzini
dell'oratorio dovevo calcolare bene i
tempi degli spostamenti trovare la
pizzeria giusta per arrivare a mangiare
insomma in modo che non fosse né troppo
presto né troppo tardi rispetto alla
partita
paradossalmente era tutto straordinari
verso da quello che io avevo fatto negli
ultimi anni della mia carriera in serie
a in agli europei e mondiali nelle world
league e altrettanto paradossalmente
quel giro lungo che io da quell'oratorio
avevo incominciato mi stava riportando
al suo inizio ora naturalmente grazie
alla solerzia degli organizzatori locali
arrivammo al campo di gioco con un
anticipo pazzesco ora
chiudete un attimo gli occhi immaginate
di essere un atleta che deve andare in
campo a giocare per una medaglia
olimpica
provate a pensar via guardare il
soffitto dello spogliatoio dovendo
aspettare più di un ora d'inizio della
gara
riuscite a immaginare la tensione e il
nervosismo quell energia nervosa che si
brucia e che però sapete che presto vi
servirà dannatamente la mia fortuna fu
quella di percepire quelle sensazioni
quello stato d'animo collettivo quindi
chiamai la squadra intorno a me e fece
un discorso di di poche parole
disse voglio raccontarvi una storia
voglio raccontarvi la storia di un
saltatore in alto un atleta come voi che
ha avuto lo stesso sogno posto per tutta
la sua vita fin da bambino vincere una
medaglia olimpica
immaginate che quell'atleta abbia
insieme al suo staff di allenatori
studiato in maniera meticolosa le
condizioni in cui dovrà competere
il 12 agosto del 2012 a londra
quindi sa ha studiato ed è consapevole
che il 12 agosto a londra normalmente ci
sono 24 gradi
c'è il 70 per cento di tasso di umidità
c'è una leggera brezza di 45 nodi che
soffia da sud est ea favore di rincorsa
e ha ricreato quelle condizioni e s'è
allenato in quelle condizioni
ogni singolo giorno negli ultimi quattro
anni è perfetto si sente pronto
si sente imbattibile poi arriva al 12
agosto del 2012
e quando quell'atleta entra nella pista
di atletica dello stadio olimpico
succede che piove piove fa freddo
la pedana scivolosa c'è un vento forte
quali sono le due scelte
la medaglia verrà comunque assegnato a
quel giorno la vincerà chi sarà più
agile e questo concetto di agilità e un
concetto ovviamente che a che fare con
la fisicità che serve agli sportivi
però è un concetto anche molto
intellettuale e una sorta di leggerezza
di capacità di muoversi in maniera
efficace di interpretare qualche
dettaglio e di rimettere insieme dei
pezzi che in quel momento sembrano
scomporsi davanti a due mani
io dissi sono certo che voi siate
consapevoli che tutto quello che avete
fatto fino ad oggi è stato importante
perché se voi non avreste avuto
quell'attenzione dettagli quella cura
del particolare quella ricerca del
protocollo oggi voi non sareste seduti
in questo spogliatoio ci sarebbe qualcun
altro posto vostro
però oggi voi dovete sbarazzarvi di
tutto quello che vi siete portati fino a
qui dovete toglierle questo zaino che è
troppo pesante e che oggi non servirà
anzi sarà di ostacolo chiusi questo
piccolo discorso dicendo una cosa molto
semplice che però sentivo davvero in
quel momento e disse semplicemente io
voglio che voi sappiate che sono
dannatamente orgoglioso di essere qui
con ciascuno di voi oggi sotto questa
pioggia
caccia è letteralmente gli atleti dallo
spogliatoio
chiesi loro di andare a fare colazione
fuori immaginatevi la scena con gli
addetti alla sicurezza che rincorrevano
gli atleti che andavano a cercare di
prendere un caffè ci demmo appuntamento
mezz'ora dopo nello stesso spogliatoio
dove io non parlai quasi più feci solo
un gesto appesi in quello spogliatoio
una maglia azzurra
la maglia dalla maglia numero 16 era la
maglia di vigor bovolenta un atleta che
aveva vestito quella maglia 197 volte
fino ai giochi olimpici di pechino e che
cinque mesi prima di quella partita era
tragicamente scomparso per un problema
cardiaco giocando a pallavolo appesi
quella maglia insieme alle altre e disse
semplicemente ricordare semplicemente
dell'importanza di non lasciarsi cose
non dette o non fatte e dicendo che in
qualche modo in qualche forma quel
giorno avremmo potuto contare su un
giocatore in più non avrei certamente
immaginato che quattro anni dopo sarei
stato chiamato a raccontare di queste
vicende un ted
però credo in quel momento di aver
pensato esattamente this must be the
place questo deve essere il posto deve
essere posto dove io dove noi
realizzeremo i nostri sogni
anche se completamente diverso da quello
che ci saremmo aspettati
sta a noi renderlo tale oggi mi venne in
mente il luogo da dove i nostri sogni
erano incominciati il foro italico lo
stadio dei marmi roma da lì la
delegazione olimpica si muove
simbolicamente per andare a ricevere la
bandiera olimpica dal presidente della
repubblica e pensai a quel luogo con un
riferimento alla leggerezza proprio
quella di italo calvino nelle lezioni
americane perché anche il foro italico è
un luogo che ha saputo trasformare
clamorosamente la destinazione per la
quale era stato pensato perché quel
luogo era stato pensato per celebrare la
pesantezza e l'orrore dell'apologia
fascista era stato pensato per dividere
il mondo
ed era stato capace di trasformarsi
ospitando nel 1960 l'edizione forse più
bella dei giochi olimpici quella di roma
quella di abebe bikila della sua corsa
leggera piedi scalzi
la maratona vinta sotto l'arco di
costantino i giochi di cassius clay i
giochi di nino benvenuti i giochi di uil
ma rudolf i giochi di un ragazzo
torinese che will marudo guardava con
tenerezza
si chiamava livio berruti e vinse i 200
metri con un'immagine meravigliosamente
romantica quella di un volo di colombe
che accompagnavano la sua curva prima
della dirittura d'arrivo che
sottolineavano quella leggerezza che
aveva trasformato anche quel luogo nato
per un obiettivo completamente diverso
nato per dividere il mondo in un luogo
dove il mondo quel giorno trovava la sua
sintesi più bella non ricordo quasi
nulla
della partita che ci ha assegnato la
medaglia ricordo la tensione e
difficoltà da superare il senso di far
parte di qualcosa di grande ricordo che
ci fu però con chiarezza in tutti noi
una sensazione non pensiamo mai neanche
per un istante che non avremmo vinto
quella partita ripensai tante volte
quello che era successo
ricordo l'ultimo punto quello che segnò
la fine di quel percorso e ricordo che
dopo quell'ultimo punto su un podio
olimpico ricomparve quella maglia che
avevamo appreso negli spogliatori con un
gesto di una bellezza straordinaria che
fece il giro del mondo
e che è ancora alla mia medaglia perché
non so se sapete con grande crudeltà ai
giochi olimpici
la medaglia agli allenatori non la danno
la medaglia ma sono gli atleti
[Applauso]
poco dopo poco dopo ripensa via calvino
guardando i miei atleti sul podio una
sensazione che vi raccontano tanti
atleti una specie di passaggio
schizofrenico fra la gioia assoluta e la
melanconia sono sorrisi che si spengono
occhi che si abbassano e come diceva
calci calvino non la melanconia che
tristezza che diventa leggera e come se
lì sul podio to scoprissi che il luogo
che quel viaggio che ti ha portato fino
a lì è finito e quell'isola di utopia
che è ricercato per tanti anni si
dissolve sotto i piedi immediatamente
appena tu ci hai messo il primo passo
sopra
ricordo anche la sera dopo quella
medaglia
passeggiavo nella all'interno del
villaggio olimpico l'ultimo giorno di
giochi ripetendomi in maniera ossessiva
che quel sogno che io avevo da bambino
era stato possibile raggiungere mi
dimostrava che non esistono sogni
impossibili e mi ripetevo questa cosa
immaginando e sentendo che io avevo in
quel momento un solo desiderio una buona
idea essere rio
quattro anni dopo in quel momento
incominciai a tratteggiare un nuovo
viaggio verso una nuova isola di utopia
pensai qualcosa del genere rio must be
the place
io però io non ci sono arrivato non ci
sono arrivato perché mi sono fermato un
mese prima delle qualificazioni per quei
giochi olimpici rassegnando le mie
dimissioni il 29 luglio del 2015
in relazione a un fatto che non voglio
raccontare perché non è importante è
importante in quel fatto avesse molto a
che fare con il rispetto delle persone
dei valori cosa che a mio giudizio non
erano non sono e non saranno mai
negoziabili non voglio giocare a fare
l'eroe
se voi mi richiede ste
lo rifaresti io non vi saprei rispondere
quella scelta mi ha procurato un dolore
immenso gigantesco e guardare alla
televisione otto atleti che con me sui
12 presenti a rio giocavano una finale
olimpica è una sensazione che
difficilmente riuscirai a descrivere
quindi non ci provo neanche voglio solo
mettervi in guardia the place
non esiste o almeno non esiste per
quanto voi vi sforziate di definirne i
dettagli non esiste come lo pensate voi
l'isola che non c'è appunto non c'è the
place è un viaggio
e allora la cosa più bella è che ogni
nostro viaggio possa essere il più lungo
possibile pieno di ricchezze di persone
da incontrare nel cammino sulla strada
piena di posti dove farsi contaminare
proprio come succede nel viaggio più
famoso della storia della letteratura
quello di ulisse c'è nel libro quinto
dello disse a un momento in cui ulisse è
sull'isola della ninfa calipso la donna
più bella del mondo che gli ha promesso
l'immortalità
se lui resterà lì con lei ora ditemi voi
la donna più bella del mondo
dell'immortalità sono due posta in palio
abbastanza significative eppure calypso
trova ulisse seduto sulla spiaggia che
guarda al mare con gli occhi e rigati di
lacrime
per questo desiderio per questa
nostalgia di ritornare alla sua isola il
desiderio la nostalgia sono un motore
dalla forza inesauribile
siate consapevoli che ci sarà sempre un
luogo verso il quale desideriamo
ritornare ma che ogni volta che ci
arriveremo
ce ne sarà un altro
di cui sentiremo la mancanza
c'è una poesia che racconta di quel
viaggio straordinario che però è anche
una meravigliosa e struggente metafora
sul senso della vita
la scritta costantino scala fis nel 1911
e si intitola itaca
[Musica]
quando ti metterai in viaggio per itaca
devi augurarti che la strada sia lunga
certain e in avventure inesperienza
lestrigoni ei ciclopi o la furia di
nettuno non temere non sarà questo un
genere di incontri
se pensi rovesta alto un sentimento
fermo guida il tuo spirito del tuo corpo
ciclopi e lestrigoni noce art nenè
l'irato nettuno incapperai se non li
porti dentro sé l'anima punte di mette
conto di augurarti che la strada sia
lunga che mattino d'estate siano tanti
quando nei porti finalmente e con che
gioia toccherai terra tool per la prima
volta negli empori fenici indugia e
acquista madre perle coralli ebano ambro
e tutta merce fina anche profumi
penetranti di ogni sorta più profumi
inebrianti che puoi va in molte città
egizia
impara una quantita di cose dai dotti
sempre devi avere in mente itaca
raggiungerla sia il tuo pensiero
costante
tuttavia non affrettare il viaggio fa
che duri a lungo per anni e che da
vecchio metta piede sull'isola to ricco
dei tesori accumulati per strada senza
aspettarti ricchezze da internet
itaca ti ha dato il bel viaggio senza di
lei mai ti saresti immesso sulla strada
che cos'altro ti aspetti e se la trovi
povera non per questo itaca ti avrà
deluso fatto ormai savio con tutta la
tua esperienza addosso già tu avrai
capito che cosa uniteca vuole
significare qualunque sia la vostra
itaca
buon viaggio
[Applauso]